[Music]
please don't make me go
you can keep homeschooling me tell you
everything I know no more argument okay
we've discussed this ad nauseam what sad
nauseam you don't know Wow looks like
someone needs school who can tell me
what three plus three this everyone
knows it's six there can you stand up
please can you tell me what 57 multiply
it by 135 this okay
who's seven thousand six hundred and
ninety-five the square root is eighty
seven point seven and change now what
does ad nauseam mean is some two moving
to the wind of my soul I think you're
nice maybe gifted I am good friends with
a headmaster of the Oakes Academy for
gifted education no I promised my sister
I'd give Mary a normal life I think
she's got to be here I've set up on the
set and son who's not lady in front of
our door that'll be your grandmother Oh
it's a Macbook darling are you doing you
are denying the girl her potential
how many seven year-olds are doing
advanced calculus forgot the negative
sign on the exponent Mary what do you
say anything thanks sis I'm not supposed
to correct older people nobody likes a
smartass we petition the court to grant
my client full custody of the child
you're gonna take that girl you're gonna
loan her out to some think-tank where
she can talk non-trivial zeros with a
bunch of old Russian guys the rest of
her life and you bury her under a rock
Evelyn stop I'm raising her how I
believe Diane would have wanted do I
need a reason we should commit treason
if anybody takes that baby away I'll
smoke you asleep bring into this my
sister wanted Mary to be a kid she
wanted her to have friends and to be
happy tell us do you have a health
insurance no did you spend the night in
jail objection unless
what's-your-face fear that I remarry
ah she's bossy I've heard that
was a good person you will need closer
yes yeah it has it's a hostile towards
all its conquest deserves the best of
all mankind and it's often too